so before we get too far into this video
I do want to say that this video may
come across as a little controversial
towards people who are comic book fans
and the reason why is because we're not
going to be talking about every aspect
of Doctor Strange we're going to be
leaving out the Civil War we're going to
be leaving out the Infinity Gauntlet
we're pretty much going to leave out
everything that takes place after Marvel
premiere issue number 10 and the reason
why is because issue number 10 is when
it becomes a sorcerer supreme and that's
what he pretty much becomes a character
and a lot of the major storylines and I
don't want to sound redundant I don't
want to go over dr. Strange's role in
the Infinity Gauntlet in this video and
then go over his role in the Infinity
Gauntlet again when we get around to
talking about the Infinity Gauntlet the
same thing for the Civil War so please
bear with me on this I apologize if it
really wasn't what you were hoping for
but I think that once it comes around to
us discussing the Civil War in the
Infinity Gauntlet I think you'll be
satisfied with our explanation on his
character and his role in those events
so Doctor Strange first appears to end
strange tales issue number 110 and as
soon as he's introduced he actually
takes a step away from the status quo
that had been created by Stanley Steve
Ditko and Roy Thomas and other creators
in Marvel Comics and what I mean by that
is when you look at other individuals
let's say characters and teams we'll
take the Fantastic Four the first major
superhero team that Marvel ever had and
we'll also use spider-man and Captain
America when you look at these
individuals and teams you see that for
the most part their origin stories are
told within the first issue of their
introduction with Fantastic Four issue
number one we learned that the Fantastic
Four gained their powers because they
were exposed to cosmic radiation and
this is explained in Fantastic Four
volume 1 issue number 1 with amazing
fantasy issue number 15 we learned that
Peter Parker is bitten by a radioactive
spider and becomes spider-man
and in Captain America comics issue
number one we learned that Steve Rogers
becomes Captain America after he has
given the super-soldier formula during
project rebirth by Abraham Erskine so
with dr. strange this doesn't happen
we're not given dr. Strange's origins
right off the bat in fact dr. strange
appears and strange tales issues number
110 111 and then issue number 14 and
then it's not until number 15 that were
given the backstory of the character now
with issues number 110 11 and 114 we are
introduced to some characters that
become relatively important one of which
is actually very important where we
learn the backstory of the characters
and those villains are nightmare and
Baron Mordo now nightmare I say is not
necessarily as important with regards to
the origin stories of Doctor Strange as
Mort Oh but nightmare does become one of
the most enduring foes of of Doctor
Strange throughout the publication
history of the character now Baron Mordo
is important to the origin of Doctor
Strange and the reason why is because an
issue number 15 when we're given the
origin story what we learn is that
Doctor Strange approaches an individual
known as the ancient one in some part of
Asia
I believe it's actually in Tibet and
he's pursuing the powers of the ancient
one who will be able to hopefully grant
him the ability to reuse his hands again
to become a neurosurgeon and at this
point the ancient one really kind of
reads the mind of dr. strange or I guess
at this point of Stephen strange and we
go on a journey into his past and what
we learn is that Stephen strange was a
very arrogant individual who really
cared nothing about charity or
compassion and was really only concerned
with his reputation and making large
sums of money eventually he's involved
in a car wreck and as a result of this
car wreck his bones are broken in his
hands and he can no longer practice
medicine until his hands are healed to
their previous state which without any
kind of what he perceives to be magical
power this simply just will not happen
on their own or by any conventional
means of surgery or medicine in the in
the Marvel Comics we ultimately see that
the ancient one refuses to assist dr.
strange Stephen strange due to the fact
that he
he is arrogant because of his past and
who the ancient one perceives him to be
at this point in time now the reason why
Baron Mordo becomes important is because
we see that dr. strange as he is leaving
comes across Baron Mordo who is
conjuring up some sorcery and invoking
the name of someone named Dormammu now
at this point we don't know who Dormammu
is but Dormammu is actually the most
dangerous foe that dr. strange faces and
I think that dr. strange even goes as
far as to say that if Dormammu were
brought into our dimension at full power
that would really not be anyone that
could stop him but what we see is that
Baron Mordo realizes that dr. strange is
effectively spying on him and he casts a
charm casts a spell that keeps dr.
strange from being able to speak about
what he has seen now Baron Mordo
approaches the ancient one and converses
with him and Doctor Strange appears as
well however dr. strange is unable to
tell the ancient one what he has seen
and heard Baron Mordo leaves and the
ancient one releases the spell that
Baron Mordo had put on dr. strange at
this point the ancient one tells dr.
strange that he has passed the test that
his desire to tell the ancient one what
was going on in the face of possible
death demonstrated the fact that in the
end he is a truly good person and at
this point we see that dr. strange
becomes a pupil of the ancient one in
this train in both physical combat and
in informed various forms of the mystic
arts now ultimately we see that the
strange tales comics come to an end with
issue number 168 and we see that they
are switched over to the Doctor Strange
comics and that's why if you were to
look up Doctor Strange vol 1 you would
see that most likely it would be Doctor
Strange volume 1 issue number 169 and
the reason for this is because Marvel
kept in numerical order of the strange
tale comics going even after volume 1
I'm sorry even after the comics have
been switched over to Doctor Strange
so volume 1 only runs for about 15
issues it's not a hugely popular comic
and over the course of these 15 issues
we really kind of get a reboot of the
character in terms of his origin story
although I would
as far as to say it's a reboot that
might be the beer wrong phrase it's
really kind of a refresh but over the
course of this 15 issue series we're
also reintroduced to some of the
villains that we saw during strange
tales nightmare Dormammu individuals
like that but due to the fact that it
was not a wildly popular character we
see vol 1 coming to a close with issue
number 15 and we see him pick back up
again and Marvel premiere issue number 3
and running to issue number 14 now the
Marvel premiere comics were a quarterly
issue of comics and what we saw here was
Doctor Strange reappearing in such a way
that he had been elevated from simply a
sorcerer to becoming the sorcerer
supreme of the Marvel Universe and what
this means is that in Marvel premiere
issue number 15 of sorry issue number 10
we see that a demon from an alternate
dimension or another dimension that had
previously existed on earth but had been
banished from our dimension was trying
to bring himself back into our dimension
by way of passing through the mind of
the ancient one now this this being this
demon was a demon named Shu McGrath and
he was an extremely powerful dementia
I'm sorry powerful demon and the world
of Marvel Comics now we eventually see
that Doctor Strange is able to stop the
efforts of Shu McGrath from getting into
our dimension although it's done so at
the cost of him having to kill the
ancient one and this is what he becomes
the sorcerer supreme
so unlike characters like magneto or
spider-man or even Wolverine the powers
of Doctor Strange are not abilities that
are inherent to him meaning that his
abilities can be taken away and the
reason why is because the powers that he
uses the effects that he creates with
those powers are derived from extra
dimensional beings Doctor Strange has a
multitude of artifacts and a multitude
of spells that have been given to him
due to the knowledge that has been given
to him either by training from a ancient
one or by direct interaction with extra
dimensional beings now who these beings
are range there are a
merci octet soms which we talked about
during our discussion on the juggernaut
and these are a group of extra
dimensional demons who came together for
the purpose of determining which one of
them was strongest but each of them has
various powers and various abilities of
course the crimson bands of cyttorak are
just one of the aspects of the powers
that Doctor Strange has the vishanti
where he receives a brunt of his
abilities come from a book called the
book of ashanti which really kind of
contains a majority of the spells that
he uses and as we progress through the
future of his YouTube channel and we
progress through future videos where we
talk about these secret wars and the
secret invasion and the civil war in the
Infinity Gauntlet and we begin to get
into discussions where understanding of
what goes on is contingent on your
knowledge of videos like this we will
begin to talk about how the vishanti in
the later volumes of Doctor Strange took
his powers away because he refused to
fight on their behalf we'll talk about
how there was a vast difference between
the powers that Doctor Strange had
during the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
and the powers that he had during the
Civil War storyline how overtime Marvel
has Dee powered the character but for
the most part in the early versions of
dr. Strange's publication history there
really wasn't a limit to the things that
he could do he was described by many
including eternity who of course was
first appeared during the strange tales
comics and the Living Tribunal who would
first appear during strange tales comics
these individuals had identified dr.
strange as being one of the four most
powerful members of the Marvel community
and this continues to be the case to
this day despite the fact that he has
been deep power to a degree he is still
very capable of going toe-to-toe with
some of the most powerful entities both
in extra dimensions and within our
dimension in the Marvel Universe and
it's for this reason that Doctor Strange
despite being a supporting character in
Marvel Comics is still a very formidable
character and a very powerful ally
because despite the fact that his powers
have been decreased he is still
extremely strong and he can still
achieve a multitude of effects with his
powers he can teleport he can read minds
he can lift objects he has telekinesis
he can project energy
energy blasts he can manipulate energy
for a wide array of different effects he
can time travel he get a look into the
future look into the past he could see
magic taking places and other dimensions
he can pull people into dimensions
there's a lot of different things that
he can do with the abilities that have
been given to him and even the ones that
I have just listed a really kind of the
tip of the iceberg we could go on for
quite some time about the different
things that he can do but suffice it to
say the powers of dr. strange put him in
a category where it's basically a lot
easier to simply say he is a rival for
virtually anyone in the Marvel Universe
with the exception of the highest
caliber individuals cosmic entities
eternity the Living Tribunal of course
the one above all and even individuals
like Galactus so for those of us who are
familiar with Doctor Strange after
seeing the movie Thor we knew right off
the bat the Doctor Strange was going to
be in the Marvel Cinematic Universe just
because we had seen the eye of agamotto
in the Hall of artifacts I think they
what they call it the vault or something
like that where you also saw the
Infinity Gauntlet and so it was very
exciting we knew exactly this character
was going to be coming it was just a
matter of what capacity he was going to
be appearing in was he going to get his
own film was he going to appear as a
member of the Avengers and possibly or
possibly not have his backstory
explained we didn't really know how this
was going to play out what we did know
is that he is going to be in some
capacity part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and so the question was how was
it going to play out and with Marvel
having come out and said that he is
going to appear with his own solo film I
think is safe safe to say that the
formula for his film will probably
follow the same formula that we've seen
with Thor and Iron Man and Captain
America where these individuals have
appeared and they have their own
backstories you know for example with
the Incredible Hulk what was really good
about that film was that the entire
origin of how Bruce Banner became the
Incredible Hulk was explained in the
opening sequence so they didn't have to
devote 45 minutes or an hour of the film
to explaining how Bruce Banner became
the Incredible Hulk but this is also due
to the fact the reason why that was able
to be done was due to the fact that
everybody knew who the Incredible Hulk
was and they knew that Bruce Banner had
on the incredible hole due to a botched
gamma-ray experiment dr. strange is not
as popular and so the question becomes
are they going to be able to do his
backstory in the opening sequence of the
film are enough people going to be able
to understand it because dr. strange has
been portrayed by various people over
time but it's never been mainstream when
you look at the Incredible Hulk The
Incredible Hulk appeared and the TV show
with Lou Lou Ferrigno his name almost
escaped me I feel like I should be
slapped for for allowing that to happen
time we saw him appear with Eric Bana in
the film The Hulk which was a terrible
movie and then we saw him up here with
Edward Norton so we know that the entire
back story of The Incredible Hulk has
been explained over and over and over
again and most everybody knows it
but because of the fact that the back
story is not widely known by a lot of
people when it comes to Doctor Strange
is Marvel going to be able to do that or
are we going to see more of a formula
like we saw with Captain America and
Thor where over the course of the first
45 minutes maybe half an hour the
backstory of the character is explained
and then everything else is the main
story arc are we going to see villains
like Dormammu or are we good simply
going to stick with Baron Mordo which
seems to be the most likely scenario
here in addition who's going to play
Doctor Strange to me there are only
three people who are really qualified to
play the character of Doctor Strange the
first of course I think is at least in
everybody's list somewhere and then of
course is Hugh Laurie because Hugh
Laurie played Gregory House and house
m.d. the critically acclaimed Fox TV
show that was absolutely amazing I love
that show and I watched it every Monday
when it came on even when it got towards
the end of the show kind of fell off but
I felt like in that TV show Hugh Laurie
was able to portray a character
fantastic he was able to portray himself
in a way to where he was a serious
individual he was he'd crack jokes every
once in a while when it got down to it
he had it where it counted and having
experience as playing a doctor I think
would really kind of go hand in hand
with him playing Doctor Strange well the
problem here is that dr. strange was
portrayed as being a neurosurgeon in
flashbacks and so for a brunt of his
publication history he's not performing
surgery on people he is a magician he's
a sorcerer and
his character exists in the realm of
performing feats of magic which leads me
into the next person the second person
that I think would be best qualified for
playing Doctor Strange would be Jason
Isaacs and the reason why is because as
far as I'm concerned if a movie has
Jason Isaacs
I will go see it I don't care what the
movie is the movie could be about Jason
Isaacs sitting in a chair and staring at
a wall for two and a half hours and I
will sit in that theater and watch that
movie to the bitter end because jason
isaacs does everything amazing when it
comes to films he's one of my favorite
actors when you look at movies like the
patriot he was fantastic in that film in
terms of portraying himself as a villain
that you hated so much that you relished
in the idea of him being stabbed through
the throat by Mel Gibson but when you
look at Harry Potter he has experienced
playing a character who deals with magic
as as the father of Draco Malfoy as
Lucius Malfoy he is an evil bad guy he
is a dark wizard now Doctor Strange
himself is not a dark magician he is not
an evil wizard however because the fact
that jason isaacs has experience playing
an individual that has delved into the
realm of magic I feel like he'd be
fantastic for this role but to me the
best person the absolute best person to
play the role of Doctor Strange
is Aiden Gillen and if you guys don't
know who that is he portrays a little
finger in Game of Thrones and this guy
looks exactly like dr. strange he looks
spot-on him this guy is the equivalent
of Val Kilmer playing Jim Morrison he
looks dead on him I mean I can't imagine
anybody else they could play this role
and watching Adrian Gillen play the
character Littlefinger he's fantastic
and queers folk he was fantastic he is a
great actor overall and while I've never
really seen him portray a character that
uses magic I really couldn't see it be
that foot being that far of a stretch
for him I really couldn't see him really
struggling to take up the role of Doctor
Strange and in fact I see him excelling
quite well in this role so with that
being said I'm gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and
and let me know who you guys think would
be a really good accurate play
strange I'm kind of curious about that
and even I will catch you guys later
peace